we'd like to analyze a physics problem
called the rocket problem in which we
have a continuous mass transfer let's
see what we mean by that let's consider
a rocket launching so here's a classic
example of a rocket that's launching off
in a gravitational field as a rocket
starts at rest it starts to burn fuel
and ejects the fuel backwards and as the
ejected fuel backwards is producing a
thrust on the rocket and you can see as
a rocket starts to rise it's starting to
accelerate upwards as fuel is ejected
backwards now this process goes on for
some time interval and a lot of fuel is
ejected backwards during that time
interval in this particular case we
could analyze the situation from the
ground frame of the rocket from the
ground frame of the earth and the fuel
is ejected backwards relative to the
rocket rocket moves up forward so how do
we analyze this situation if we just
looked at the rocket when the rocket
initially launched the mass of the
rocket is the dry mass of the rocket
plus all the fuel in there it's at rest
in a state much later on the mass of the
rocket has decreased and the speed is
increased but we can't just compare this
initial to this final state because
throughout this process there was a
continuous mass transfer fuel was
ejected backwards so how do we analyze
these types of continuous mass transfer
problems and the key is again
identifying States so for a continuous
mass transfer problem we always have to
choose a reference frame so here in our
example we were choosing the ground
frame of the earth and then we want to
identify two states we don't want to
identify the initial and the final
States we want to pick two arbitrary
states that are separated by a small
time interval so we can take a state at
time T and then our second state occurs
at a small
afterwards time T plus delta-t
and what we want to do is now represent
the state changes by momentum diagrams
and that will lead us to a differential
equation which is called the rocket
equation and that's how we'll analyze
all continuous mass transfer problems in
applying the momentum principle our
first thing is just to choose a
reference frame so in our example we're
going to choose the ground frame of the
earth as a reference frame now the next
step is the key to these processes
instead of choosing some initial state
where the rocket is at rest and some
final state much later on we want to
choose two states that are separated by
a small time interval delta T so our
first state at time T and our second
state we choose at time T plus delta T
now the next step is that we have to
identify what is our system and so in
this case our system is going to be the
mass of the rocket at time T that mass
is the dry mass of the rocket plus all
the fuel that's still in the rocket at
time T and this mass will stay the same
between times T and T plus delta T even
though some of the mass has been ejected
downward so our next step is to look at
that mass conservation of the system